good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can be a
better leader the Y clip is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end for some special
bonus clips as well as my thoughts and
as always if you hear something that
really resonates with you something that
really hit the mark please leave in the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
I think building an organization
building a team
the idea that Jack Welch is the hero of
creating all this value is silly getting
great people in all these jobs it's a
team that makes this thing happen and so
building a team is your strongest suit
and you've got to love your team you
don't want your team to be promoted and
when you're coming up the biggest
problem I find with young MBAs at first
the job is you shiny raising your hand
having the answers they want to do that
all the time they just go to school they
want to show you how smart they are
now the transition to manager it all
changes it's about growing your people
not you you grow from the reflected
glory of your people so it's all about
making them flourish I like to use the
line that your job is walking around
with a can of water in one hand I can't
a fertilizer in the other hand
sprinkling on the seeds and watching
them grow you'll get some weeds and you
got to pull those weeds out so
everyone's not gonna flourish but you've
got to be thinking about all the time
loving to see your people thrive loving
to see them get promoted it's a real
turn-on it is what management's all
about it's about bringing to people
great lives great futures changing their
family's life that's a turn-on
it's a big deal that's what you're gonna
think about
my number-one belief about leadership is
you're a servant but here's what I mean
here's what I mean specifically the word
hero hero that isn't the archetype of
like men and you and I abet it's my is
it true that inside of you you want you
wouldn't want to be the best you want to
create the best share the best do the
best is that is that a metaphor for you
in your life absolutely yeah me too
so I think people in this room tend to
have that as their metaphor so all of us
at some level man or woman wants to be
hero the word hero if latin root means
servo servo means servant
it actually means slave the hero why
they're the hero has become the ultimate
servant to something larger than
themselves people and so forth the
person who thinks they're gonna lead by
demand or by position can only leave for
a short period of time but the person
whose idea serving as my belief is if
you can find a way to take any group of
people and help them to experience their
needs at a richer deeper level than
anyone else then together you guys can
get anything done anything now it may
not work the first time but together you
can get to that point because needs are
ultimately we're after we're not after
the vehicle we think Raptor you want a
billion dollars then you get it I got
plenty clients and I will tell you it is
not the end game and so they have been
they go after their second billion or or
you think it's getting married and then
you get it you find out it's not the end
game there's certain needs that have to
be there and the ultimate needs are
growing and giving because you only can
feel so good filled up by yourself so my
core belief is I got a serve if I serve
I can lead because I believe motive does
matter if my motive is just to get you
to do something for me there's a certain
amount of power that I can get to do
that if I strategize if I think if I
feel and also if it serves a greater
good even if I don't intend it if the
bumble bee goes to try to get the nectar
it wants it's selfish goal I believe
there's a higher power of the guys at
all and when that bumble bee goes it
doesn't intend to give anything but
pollen sticks to its legs as it goes
about trying to get what it wants
that's how flowers are created I really
believe that everything has a
of connection if your intent is to serve
yourself you're still going to serve
something more than yourself
and you're going to get a certain amount
of insight if you're intent in your
motive is to serve something yourself
but also something more just your kids
then I believe you get a different level
of insight and because you're serving
more of what serves life it's not just
me it's me and my family if you're
trying to serve a community I believe
you get a different level of insight
treasure of humanity you get a did well
inside I get emotional think about this
is why I do what I do so when someone
stands up it's not about business it's
not about anything but about serving
them so I will use abrasive or creative
language I'll use whatever takes humor
stupidity I'll make fun of myself I'll
challenge I'll do anything to serve
that's why I'm here I don't need to do
more but I love to see someone free and
alive and lit up so when that's your
motive
you matter how people perceiving it
outside if they're around you long
enough
you can't hide what your real motive is
and they'll see it and they'll feel it
motive does matter if it's to serve
something high it'll be that that
doesn't mean you don't get served too
and in business you gotta be served or I
used to do business and I lose money the
business everybody else was happy and it
was wonderful except I had no business
so it's you know killing the goose that
lays the golden eggs so I've learned to
put that battle in sin but that gives me
power that's why time disappears for me
because I'm not about getting some
action done I'm about the outcome my
first job out of college I had a boss
who believed it was appropriate to
berate people to get the most out of
them and I remember this is a true story
I actually sat down with her we used to
have these sort of monthly career
updates you know and she literally said
to me you have no talent quote unquote
and I went none and she said none you
know and the good news was I thought
that was funny
could you kind of have none like if you
told me I only could do one thing that
actually probably would've hurt more but
nothing you know nothing and so I really
paid attention as to how she managed and
the rest of my career did the complete
opposite
give me an example I but you know I
think that pointing out people's
strengths is a lot better than telling
them they have no talent also she had
this belief that if you don't look
harried and insane
then you then you might then you're not
working hard you know so I remember
pretending that I was like stressed out
whose have I sauntered down the hallway
and said hi to people she thought I was
doing nothing right so I started
pretending his like I can talk I can
talk and that way she thought I was very
busy and she left me alone
yeah honesty in management you know
treating people with respect being
honest about what they they can and
can't do and committing yourself to
helping people not not hurting people or
pushing them down has been more
effective for me sometimes at work it's
not what's happening it worked for a lot
of stressed out managers especially it's
what's happening outside of work how do
you try to figure out where the sources
of the issue may be to cut past some of
the challenges you face communicating
when I was entry-level having empathy
for my boss didn't factor in you know
not knowing anything about sort of my
place in the company etc but as I've as
I've grown up I realized that the only
motivation for any kind of confrontation
whether you're the one who's confronting
someone because you feel that they have
done something wrong or whether you're
confronting them because you feel that
you've been wronged you know the only
the only motivation is empathy and so
even if someone has is coming down on me
hard or being unreasonable or being you
know I've I'm not perfect at it but I've
worked really hard to approach it with
you you know confronting them that
they've hurt me or is that I feel
wronged but but immediately go into the
considering that maybe there is
something that's bothering them and and
that has proved to be really helpful and
and we do it in in life I mean for
example you know somebody sitting next
to you on the subway is you know
slouched back their legs open and your
immediate sort of reaction is to think
what an ass you know but the idea of
practicing and say well maybe had a hard
day less like yesterday and he's
exhausted and he just doesn't want to
deal you know maybe he doesn't want to
talk to people you know
and so to to really just sort of have
empathy for the world around you it's
it's kind of powerful and people respond
to you a lot better as well because
basically everybody wants to feel safe
and so if you have empathy you you give
that to people
upward down the chain of command I mean
we we as employees want to feel safe and
those our bosses responsibility to give
us that but at the same time bosses want
to feel safe they don't want to feel
that there's insurrection you know that
that's brewing and and for us to let
them know that we've got their back as
much as we want them to let us know that
they have ours is equally as important
and I believe there is responsibility of
a manager but there's a responsibility
of an employee as well you know it's
like the kids have to do chores at home
you know it's the kind of same thing
it's like we all it takes all of us yeah
the hierarchy doesn't doesn't mean that
only the guys above are the ones with
responsibility we all we all have to
contribute one of the keys to Apple is
Apple's an incredibly collaborative
company and so you know how many
committees we have at Apple no zero you
have no committees no committee we are
there we are organized like a start-up
one person is in charge of iPhone OS
software one person is in charge of Mac
hardware one person is in charge of
iPhone hardware engineering another
person is in charge of worldwide
marketing another person is in charge of
operations it's we're organized like a
start-up we're the biggest startup on
the planet and we all meet for three
hours once a week and we talk about
everything we're doing the whole
business and there's tremendous teamwork
at the top of the company which filters
down to tremendous teamwork throughout
the company and teamwork is dependent on
trusting the other folks to come through
with their part without watching them
all the time but trusting that they're
going to come through with their parts
and that's what we do really well and
we're great at figuring out how to
divide things up in the
great teams that we have and all work on
the same thing touch bases frequently
and bring it all together into a product
we do that really well and so what I do
all day is meet with teams of people and
work on ideas and solve problems to make
new products to make new marketing
programs whatever it is and our people
willing to tell you you're wrong yeah I
mean other than snarky journalists I
mean people are ya know we have
wonderful arguments and do you win them
all or oh no I wish I did
Oh see you can't if you want to hire
great people and have them stay working
for you you have to let them make a lot
of decisions and you have to you have to
be run by ideas not hierarchy the best
ideas have to win so otherwise good
people don't stay when you begin leading
a new business or take on a new
leadership role in a business you'll
usually be relatively inexperienced in
the cotton thrust of business activities
because of your lack of experience you
will go into business with the wrong
people and hire the wrong people and get
involved with the wrong people at many
levels now this is normal and natural
and it's to be expected at the beginning
the key is to always be growing as a
person and as a leader as you continue
to grow and learn it will reflect on all
parts of your life and in all parts of
your business there's a universal
principle that you've heard of called
the law of attraction this law says that
you always attract into your life the
people and ideas and resources in
harmony with your dominant thoughts the
fact is that you are a living magnet
like iron filings are attracted to a
magnet you attract into your life the
people who are in harmony with your
current level of knowledge and wisdom
and experience the good news is that as
your leadership skills grow and mature
you'll attract into your life better and
better people you will attract better
employees and better customers and
better suppliers and better
bankers and better associates but you'll
always get the people that you deserve
based on your current level of personal
and professional development the more
you learn and grow the more experiences
you have that you benefit from and the
wiser you become as a business person
the faster and more consistently your
business will grow as well you'll always
attract the type of people who are in
harmony with your own level of personal
development the rule is your life only
gets better on the outside when you get
better on the inside now your people
only get better when you become a better
manager your customers only get better
when you become a better salesperson
your business only gets better when you
become a better business person there
are no shortcuts and there's no other
way fortunately you are in complete
control of every aspect of your life so
always be improving yourself and you'll
start to improve every other aspect of
your life around you including your
leadership abilities continue to improve
your leadership skills and qualities by
practicing these things reading your
field on a regular basis always be
reading about the best practices and the
leadership skills that you can use in
your personal development as a leader
and try them out every day listen to
audio programs on business and
leadership success and try out what you
learn on those programs attend business
seminars this is one of the greatest
learning tools in history you can gain
new perspectives and ideas relating to
your field and then put these ideas into
action share ideas in your business
mastermind groups and gain ideas from
other people if something is working
well for someone else in your field
there's a good chance it will work for
you as well use other people's great
ideas to improve on yourself as you
improve on the inside your business and
every part of your life will improve on
the outside the only limits on what you
can accomplish in your business are
those limits you set on yourself with
your own thinking you can go as fast and
as far as you want on your way to wealth
it's completely up to you a boss is
entire job is to get the combined
intellect of his team to be raised to a
new level and to instill spirit find
every way to celebrate find every excuse
to have a party but every little victory
counts I mean it is so if a boss can't
energize if he or she can't excite and
make people want to be there they
shouldn't have that title so think about
my philosophy on leadership I believe
that it's a leaders job to identify the
limiting beliefs that hold the people on
their team back I think you need to help
the people on your team believe in
themselves more and help them expose
these things that have been holding them
back and give them the path to
breakthrough and give them the
confidence and courage and abilities to
break through I think it's important
that when you are challenging somebody
to push and grow and learn and get
better that it's all done with their
self-interest in mind not yours and
often those will be aligned somebody's
self-interest to be a better salesperson
a better programmer a better graphic
designer right if that's one of their
ambitions that's great for you to being
the leader sometimes it means that you
push them away from the company right it
means that they have to go off and do
something else because their dream is to
be a baker and you don't have an
opportunity for baking in your company
so don't stick with me and be a C or D
player here go being a player over there
people will only do something for you
for so long if you are forcing somebody
to do something forces I'm going to show
up on time forces somebody to hit this
deadline forcing somebody to grow they
will do it for a while because you're
paying their bills because you know
maybe they respect you because they
really want to make you happy but when
people will really really give you
everything they've got it's because they
see how it benefits them it's because
it's in their best interest to do it and
it's not it's not a sales job it's not
trying to convince them that doing this
action is going to be good for them it's
truly coming from a place of I want you
to get better for yourself whether that
means you stay with our company or not
if you are going to be around us you
were going to get better we are going to
help
you break through these limiting
personal believes these actions that are
holding you back and I think a good
leader brings that with them they bring
a desire to make everything around them
better the people around them better the
environment around them better the
customers around them better because
it's in their best interest and not
yours and they happen to line up a lot
of the times which helps you in your
business
so that's my quick take I'd love to know
what do you think about leadership what
are some of the skills that you've
learned some of the tricks tactics that
you've learned that helped you become a
better leader or some of the things that
you are trying to learn please leave in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion also what was your favorite
clip in this video what did you learn
the most from some of the people who
shared some thoughts today leave in the
comments again I'll join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Abhishek asked
me to so if there's a topic you'd like
me to cover in the next edition of
believe life leaving the comments below
and I'll see what I can do finally
wanted to give a quick shout of to local
Toronto entrepreneur Frank Hoffman Frank
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book thank you for tweeting that
awesome picture out I know there's a lot
of other people's books in that picture
but your one word is on the top and so I
really really appreciate that Frank I
hope you enjoyed the book so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is
much love I'll see you soon
so there's a wonderful story I think
that's listening has the problem when
people say you need to be a better
listener is we are human beings and we
need to communicate that communication
is to waste listening and speaking so
the but everybody's like you got to be a
better listener like but here's the best
understanding I have that so Nelson
Mandela is universally regarded as a
great leader which is important because
you know different people are viewed
differently in different nations but
Nelson Mandela universally regarded as a
great leader right he was actually the
son of a tribal chief and he was asked
in an interview once how did you learn
to be a great leader and he tells the
story of how he would go to tribal
meetings with his father and he
remembers two things they always sat in
a circle and his father was always the
last to speak hmm and in terms of
leadership and listening I think the
idea of be a better listener is actually
half the advice I think the advice is
practice being the last to speak you see
this all the time in meetings where
everybody will sit around the room the
senior guy would be like all right
here's the problem here's what I think
we should do but I'm really interested
in what your thoughts are yes let's go
around the room it's too late you've
influenced you know created your Ukraine
and people and it paid people bend and
mold as opposed to saying here's a
problem I'm interested what you have to
say without saying anything and not even
and having this then here's this takes
practice not even even giving a hint
whether you agree or disagree if
anything you ask questions to learn more
you get the benefit of hearing
everybody's opinion everybody gets to
feel heard and then you get to render so
I would call is part of the interviewing
process do you have essentially a
culture check like yes but not like
checklist culture is always something
that we interview for of kind of
curiosity and and you know it's easy to
find people who say oh I read the NEFAs
culture deck I love it I really want to
be there you know what's harder is old
you know what are the main things you
disagree with and why you know and when
we get a blank stare or were like okay
not really a first principle thinker and
when they say well I thought the way
that you didn't talk about how to
acculturate and you know if I'm not
great and day three am I out you know or
is there you know do you look at it like
athlete where it's over some you know
time period to prove yourself and if so
what's that time period and why haven't
you clarified that
then we're like ah yeah that's a good
insight first
rinsable thinker so we're looking for
people who you know are curious
typically self-confident and they're not
they're questioning everything around
them another important quality of an
effective leader is to be a role model
to be the kind of person that everyone
else looks up to it wants to be like
this is true in your work in your
personal life it's true in your family
but it's also true as a manager
effective leaders carry themselves at
all times even when no one is watching
as if everyone was watching leaders
imagine that they live in a goldfish
bowl and everyone is watching the leader
in the leadership role they are very
aware of the impact of their words and
gestures on the people around them they
realize that what they say has
tremendous impact so you must always be
sensitive to the fact that everything
you say or do is magnified Moute many
times by the people who look up to or
look up to you for guidance a positive
remark from you to someone over whom you
exert influence or control as
inordinately positive effects a negative
remark or criticism from you has
inordinately negative effects the impact
of both are multiplied so choose your
words and your behavior with care if you
aspire to become an inspirational and
effective leader you must continuously
work on yourself and improve your
management skills no one starts off as
an effective leader or manager but you
can aspire to improve your skills by
learning what leaders do and how they
think and how they feel and then by
copying them until you become one
yourself
remember leaders are made not born and
they are self-made through personal
development